wayne wright molina are trying to get
the cardinals into the postseason
adam wainwright this will be a
significant start for him
no matter what and you can put any kind
of label on it you wish
sends that one to right field over goes
dexter fowler again
he'll handle two outs in the inning
brandon woodruff is a very big start for
woodruff
it's a big man he's going to come right
at you as hard
hard hard hard going to get it up there
about 96 97 miles an hour
that is in there for strike three 96 at
the knees for strikeout for brandon
woodruff two down
swing and a miss and fastball running
away strikes him out back-to-back case
for woodruff
now paul deyoung the pitch swaying and a
miss
and the young is gone strikeout number
three
for brandon woodruff
strikes him out picks up strikeout
number forward through two without a
score in saint louis
huge opportunity right now for the
brewery trying to pitch his way out of
the first jam he's really been in
two and two on yelich who's gone six for
16 against wainwright the pitch
swinging a ground ball fair the first
baseman has it and goldschmidt wins the
race to the bag beating yellidge three
and assisted
great pitching by wainwright first and
third one out he struck out garcia
got yelling to ground out brewers
cardinals fourth inning no score
this one is in the air to right and deep
back goes fowler he's at the wall and
that ball is gone ryan braun with a home
run
puts the brewers on top one to nothing
is eighth home run of the year and the
brewers strike first
he shoots this thing out to right center
again braun
he's got a long history against wayne
right you know he's battled him over the
years and
knows his tendencies faced him a ton of
times
it's his third home run off wayne right
right
one nothing brewers now daniel vogel
back and he hits one in the air
deep left center carlson watching
vogelback has gone back to back with
braun
two-nothing brewers vogel back with his
fourth in a brewers uniform
there was no doubt about that dylan
carlson started to drift back
and then just started to pull up
second time through for the crew and
they go back to back
another sinker middle away and vogel
back just split the baseball in half
you can tell by the swings that these
cardinal hitters have
woodruff stuff is great it's average
fastball velocity at 96.4
i've seen 98. and that one at 98. and
that one's by him that's five strikeouts
for woodruff
second time brad miller is down by way
of the k
ready to work woodruff the pitch and he
struck him out
woodruff with a three up and three down
fourth and a shut down inning of the
saint louis cardinals
six strikeouts for brandon woodruff
through four brewers leading the
cardinals two nothing
heading into the fifth second fastball
in right in on the hands here it comes
and that is strike three 97 and on the
corner
strikeout number seven long trying to
find his way on
and it is the pitcher woodruff who fires
to first base nicely done
able to get long for round number two of
the sixth inning
is going to jump out there but it is
woodruff i mean if there was ever a game
that the brewers needed a big pitching
performance
it's tonight and everybody knows it
their season's on the brink
and woodruff has stepped up and he has
just been dominant
two nothing brewers with two outs here
in the sixth inning
and a full count to tommy edmond
and a swing and a miss elevates at 97
and strikes him out
8k is for woodruff he's retired 15 in a
row omar narvaez
trying to add on for the brewers here in
the seventh inning
and that one kind of a hanger he'll line
it into center field for a base hit
coming around trying to score is garcia
the throw is up the line and the brewers
take a three-nothing
lead a two-out rbi single for omar
narvaez and the brewers take a
three-nothing lead
not much production all year from their
buyers but
they'll take it here very important adam
wainwright departs
and could this be his last game in a
cardinals uniform
last year of his contract and of course
cardinals need to win here to get into
the postseason so not a sure thing that
he'll get another start
they need to win out philly's loss of
one of the last two games that needs san
francisco to lose one of the last two
games
and here is josh hayder trying to nail
it down for the brewers
[Music]
goldsmith will pop it up foul ground
jerko is over
and he's got to play and he makes it and
the milwaukee brewers
come into st louis and they shut out the
st louis cardinals in a game that they
absolutely had to have and they got it